There's a reason why I'm sharing my favorite Katie Mingle story with you, and if you absolutely can't wait to find out that reason, let's give a head 25 minutes or so. But it would be cooler if we just took this walk together. Come on, Rambler. Say it with me. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When producer Katie Mingle's dad retired, he began walking.
我分享我最喜欢的凯蒂·明格 (Katie Mingle) 的故事是有原因的，如果你完全等不及想知道那个原因，我们大概可以把时间往前调个 25 分钟左右。但如果我们只是结伴散步，那就更酷了。来吧，漫步者。跟我一起说。这是 99% 隐形 (99% Invisible)。我是罗曼·马尔斯 (Roman Mars)。当制片人凯蒂·明格的爸爸退休时，他开始散步。
A lot. He'd always been a walker, but with all the new time on his hands, his walking took on a forest, gumpian, fervor. He started doing these really long, multi-day treks through the countryside. And even though he's American, he mostly preferred to walk in the UK. In fact, over the course of several years, he walked the entire length of Great Britain. And on one of these many trips in 2003. I was walking through this beautiful, rolling hills and wooded area and there were,
非常多。他一直很喜欢散步，但有了这么多空闲时间后，他的散步带有一种《阿甘正传》式的狂热。他开始进行那些非常漫长的、持续多日的乡间徒步旅行。尽管他是美国人，但他大多更喜欢在英国散步。事实上，在好几年的时间里，他走遍了整个大不列颠。那是 2003 年，在无数次旅行中的其中一次里。我正走在这些美丽、起伏的丘陵和林区里，有，
there were just literally hundreds and hundreds of pheasants and grouse along this trail and you'd walk along and they would fly up in the air. That's my dad, Jim Mingle. I walked and walked and it got later and later and I realized I couldn't get back to my B&B where I was staying. So I decided I would hitchhike back. Hitchhiking is dangerous, Dad, but go on. I stuck out my thumb and up pulled this Jeep, and I hopped in, and there was this guy sitting there, all dressed in sort of traditional,
沿着这条小路， буквально（字面意思）有成百上千只野鸡和松鸡，你走着走着它们就会飞到空中。那是我的爸爸，吉姆·明格 (Jim Mingle)。我走啊走，天越来越晚，我意识到我无法回到我住的 B&B（住宿加早餐旅馆）了。所以我决定搭便车回去。搭便车很危险，爸爸，不过你继续说。我伸出大拇指，一辆吉普车停了下来，我跳了上去，有个家伙坐在那里，穿着一身很传统的，
tweed outfit. There was a funny cap, and there was a shotgun on the rack in the back, which you you never ever saw in Britain. And we got to talking and he said he was the gamekeeper for Madonna and Guy Richie. My dad had been walking through Madonna's private estate when he was picked up by her gamekeeper. Which is a thing a lot of wealthy landowners have in England, a person who manages the hunting activity on their land. Right, so this gamekeeper drove him back to the village where he was staying and dropped
花呢服装。戴着一顶滑稽的帽子，后座的架子上还放着一把猎枪，这在英国是绝对绝对看不到的。我们聊了起来，他说他是麦当娜 (Madonna) 和盖·里奇 (Guy Ritchie) 的看守人。我爸爸在穿过麦当娜的私人庄园时，被她的猎场看守人顺车载了一程。在英国，很多富有的大地主都有这种职业，也就是管理他们土地上狩猎活动的人。对，所以这个猎场看守人把他载回了他住的村庄，并把他放下了。
him off. And no, his story doesn't end with him meeting Madonna. I wish it did too. And I ask about Madonna how he liked this gamekeeper-like working for her. And he said, he loved his job and he thought Madonna was just wonderful. Is your favorite Madonna song, Dad? Oh, I have no idea. I just like the idea of Madonna.
不，他的故事并没有以他见到麦当娜而结束。我也希望是这样。我问起麦当娜，问他觉得这个像猎场看守人一样的工作为她干得怎么样。他说，他很热爱他的工作，而且他觉得麦当娜简直太棒了。爸爸，你最喜欢的麦当娜的歌是什么？哦，我毫无头绪。我只是喜欢麦当娜这个概念。
I'm not very good at remembering those kinds of things. Now that we've established that Madonna is wonderful and my dad can't name a single one of her songs, you might be asking yourself as I was. Dad, what were you doing in Madonna's backyard? I was walking most of the time across private property. I was walking from one field to the next climbing over the fence where they are through a gate and going on and this was this was permitted. It's true my dad walked the length of Great Britain and was on private property a lot of the time which is different obviously than the way we do things in the US. If you wanted to walk across this country you'd have to do it on a combination of public trails and roads, and you certainly couldn't cut across Madonna's property.
我不太擅长记住那种事情。既然我们已经确定了麦当娜很棒，而我爸爸连她的一首歌都说不出来，你可能也会像我一样问自己：爸爸，你在麦当娜的后院里干什么呢？我大部分时间都在私人土地上步行。我从一个田地走到另一个田地，翻过围栏，或者穿过大门继续前行，而且这是被允许的。千真万确，我爸爸走遍了整个大不列颠，而且大部分时间都在私人土地上，这显然与我们在美国的做法不同。如果你想徒步穿过这个国家，你必须结合公共小路和道路来走，而且你肯定不能从麦当娜的房产上直接穿过去。
This right in Britain, to walk through private land, is known colloquially as the Right to Rome, and the movement to win this right was started in the 1930s by a rebellious group of young people dressed in army surplus shorts and hiking boots, carrying canvas and rucksacks and canteens. They called themselves Ramblers. Rambler is one of those quite old English words. I don't know where it came from really, but it means walking or hiking in the countryside. This is Rulie Smith, a Rambler slash journalist
在英国，这种穿过私人土地的权利俗称“漫游权”（Right to Rome），而争取这一权利的运动始于 20 世纪 30 年代，当时有一群叛逆的年轻人，他们穿着军队的剩余物资短裤和徒步靴，背着帆布背包和水壶。他们自称为“漫步者”（Ramblers）。“漫步者”是那种非常古老的英国词汇。我不知道它到底从何而来，但它的意思就是在乡间散步或徒步旅行。这是鲁利·史密斯 (Rulie Smith)，一位漫步者兼记者，
who says his rambling forefathers and mothers were toiling away in the factories of 1930s Manchester. Manchester was a very grimy town, a very dirty, smoky, horrible environment, a product really of the industrial revolution. Outside Manchester was one of the most beautiful parts of England, an area known as the Peak District. So if you can imagine factory workers in Manchester and Sheffield could actually see these inviting mowers from their homes and their workplaces and they weren't allowed to walk on them.
他表示，他的漫步者先辈们当时正在 20 世纪 30 年代的曼彻斯特工厂里辛苦劳作。曼彻斯特是一个非常阴暗的小镇，一个非常肮脏、烟雾弥漫、糟糕透顶的环境，这其实是工业革命的产物。曼彻斯特郊外是英格兰最美丽的部分之一，一个被称为峰区（Peak District）的地区。所以，如果你能想象的话，曼彻斯特和谢菲尔德的工厂工人实际上从他们的家和工作场所就能看到这些迷人的荒野，但他们却不被允许在上面行走。
It hadn't always been this way. For hundreds of years, an idea of the commons had existed in England. So the commons, they were an integral part of medieval life for the ordinary villager in England. That's Ken Ilguna's author of this land is Yerland, how we lost the right to Rome and how to take it back. All the land, it was owned by either a king or a lord, but the peasants had very substantial and real rights on these common lands. In this feudal system, kings and lords controlled all the land, and the manor grew enough food to support itself and its tenants. The peasants lived on the land, sometimes without written leases, but with assumed rights
情况并非一直如此。几百年来，英格兰一直存在着“公有地”（commons）的概念。因此，公有地是英格兰普通村民中世纪生活不可或缺的一部分。这是肯·伊尔古纳斯 (Ken Ilgunas)，著有《这片土地是你的土地：我们是如何失去漫游权以及如何夺回它的》(This Land is Yerland, How We Lost the Right to Rome and How to Take It Back)。所有的土地，要么属于国王，要么属于领主，但农民在这些公有地上拥有非常实质性和真实的权利。在这个封建制度中，国王和领主控制着所有的土地，庄园产出足够养活自己及其佃农的粮食。农民们在这片土地上生活，有时没有书面租约，但享有公认的权利，
to use it in exchange for various types of service. They could graze their cattle, cut lumber, they could draw water, they could collect peat, they could use it for a whole bunch of purposes. All of that began to change in the 1400s when wool prices rose across Europe. Landowners wanted it on the profits and in order to graze sheep more efficiently, they needed to fence off pastures. And that's when we began to see a period of enclosure. Landowners cleared entire villages of people making them homeless and put up little stone walls
可以用它来换取各种劳务。他们可以放牧牛群、砍伐木材、取水、收集泥炭，他们可以将其用于各种用途。这一切在 15 世纪开始改变，当时全欧洲的羊毛价格上涨。土地所有者想要获得利润，为了更高效地放牧绵羊，他们需要用栅栏围起牧场。正是在那个时候，我们开始看到一个圈地运动（enclosure）时期。土地所有者清理了整个村庄的人口，让他们无家可归，并建起了小石墙，
and hedges to mark the boundaries of their property. In a county called Warwickshire, 61 villages were wiped out before the year 1500. Over the years, Parliament created more and more laws to keep people from using what was once common land. It all ramped up in the 1700s. There was nearly 4,000 acts of parliament between 1760 and 1870. That's a sixth of England that went from common lands to enclosed private property, destroying people's livelihoods in way of life. People were so desperate to continue hunting on this once common land that they came at night and covered their faces in soot for extra camouflage. They became known
和树篱来标记他们财产的边界。在一个叫沃里克郡 (Warwickshire) 的县，在 1500 年之前就有 61 个村庄被抹去了。多年来，议会制定了越来越多的法律，阻止人们使用曾经的公有地。这一切在 18 世纪愈演愈烈。在 1760 年到 1870 年间，大约有 4000 项议会法案。这相当于英格兰六分之一的土地从公有地变成了封闭的私人财产，摧毁了人们的生计和生活方式。人们拼命地想要继续在这片曾经的公有地上狩猎，以至于他们在夜间到来，并在脸上涂满煤灰作为额外的伪装。他们被称为，
as the blacks and in 1723 Parliament passed the Black Act. So this Black Act, it created 50 offenses that were punishable by death for people who were accessing this land. Eventually, the death penalty for trespassing was done away with, but the land remained closed to the vast majority of people. In the 1800s, Britain industrialized, and people found themselves indoors all day and unable to find places for recreation. England did not have a national park system at this time, and the trails that people could access were extremely limited.
“黑人群体”（the blacks），1723 年，议会通过了《黑色法案》（Black Act）。因此，这个《黑色法案》针对进入这片土地的人制定了 50 项可被判处死刑的罪行。最终，私闯民宅的死刑被废除了，但土地仍然对绝大多数人关闭。在 19 世纪，英国实现了工业化，人们发现自己整天待在室内，找不到娱乐的地方。当时英国没有国家公园系统，人们可以进入的小径也极为有限。
Still, the people longed to be in the hills. They walked where they could and trespassed where they couldn't. They climbed over fences and tried to stay hidden from the gamekeepers. And all over England, so-called Rambling Club started to form. The Forest Ramblers Club, the Midlands Institute of Ramblers, the Manchester Rambling Club, there were tons of these walking groups in the late 1800s and early 1900s forming to fight for access and walking rights. They oftentimes had socialist sensibilities, but at the heart there was a love for walking
尽管如此，人们依然渴望身处山峦之中。他们在能走的地方走，在不能走的地方私闯。他们翻越栅栏，努力躲避猎场看守人的视线。在整个英格兰，所谓的“漫步俱乐部”开始成立。“森林漫步者俱乐部”（The Forest Ramblers Club）、“米德兰兹漫步者学会”（The Midlands Institute of Ramblers）、“曼彻斯特漫步俱乐部”（The Manchester Rambling Club），在 19 世纪末和 20 世纪初，有大量的这类步行团体成立，为争取通行权和步行权而战。他们通常带有社会主义情怀，但在心底，他们对步行有着无限的热爱，
and a belief that it was there right. Access was no longer a matter of survival as it had been in the days when enclosure began. It was about recreation and getting away from the polluted industrial cities. Which brings us back to polluted industrial 1930s Manchester, a rambling club called the British Workers' Sports Federation. The British Workers' Sports Federation? And in this group was a charismatic rambler named Benny Rothman. A stocky little character, a very broad grin and great sense of humour. And a man of the highest principles but he was exceptionally short, he was about
并坚信这是他们的权利。通行权不再像圈地运动开始时那样是个生存问题。它关乎娱乐和远离污染的工业城市。这就把我们带回了受污染的 20 世纪 30 年代工业化曼彻斯特，一个名为“英国工人体育联合会”（British Workers' Sports Federation）的漫步俱乐部。英国工人体育联合会？这个群体里有一位极具个人魅力的漫步者，名叫本尼·罗斯曼 (Benny Rothman)。一个矮壮的小人物，带着非常灿烂的微笑和极好的幽默感。他是一个有着崇高原则的人，但他个子极矮，用我们的话说，大约只有，
five foot nothing as we say. Really actually got to know Benny later in life. He was a man who I very much looked up to although he was very short. So one day back in 1932, a few people from Benny's group tried to take a walk in the Hills near Manchester in that beautiful mountainous area near the city called the Peak District and they were chased off by a group of gamekeepers and when they got back to their camp Benny Rothman and others said you know if there was enough of us they couldn't stop us. So Benny and the other ramblers came up with an idea. Let's get a huge group together and walk onto this mountain called Kinderskout. Which was the biggest mountain in this peak district.
五英尺高（不到1米6）。其实我是在晚年才真正认识本尼的。他是一个我很敬仰的人，尽管他个子很矮。所以回到 1932 年的那一天，本尼团队的几个人试图在曼彻斯特附近的群山中散步，在城市附近那个美丽的山区，被称为峰区（Peak District）的地方，他们被一群猎场看守人驱赶了。当他们回到营地时，本尼·罗斯曼和其他人说，你知道吗，如果我们人数足够多，他们就阻止不了我们。于是，本尼和其他漫步者想出了一个主意。让我们组织一个庞大的群体，走到这座名为金德斯考特 (Kinderskout) 的山上。这是峰区最大的山。
It was called the Forbidden Mountain. And this area, this was guarded by a whole bunch of gamekeepers. These were intimidating men. I mean, they would use telescopes to identify trespassers from afar. They carried these big sticks or clubs that they would sometimes use on trespassers. The British Workers' Sports Federation did not keep their plans to trespass a secret. They gave an interview to the local paper saying, we feel we cannot any longer submit to being deprived of the beauties of the
它被称为“禁山”。这片区域由一大群猎场看守人把守。这些人令人望而生畏。我的意思是，他们会用望远镜从远处识别私闯者。他们带着大棍子或大棒，有时会用这些东西对付私闯者。英国工人体育联合会并没有对他们私闯的计划保密。他们接受了当地报纸的采访，称：“我们觉得我们不能再为了地主的便利，而继续忍受被剥夺欣赏，
countryside for the convenience of the landowners. Wherever we claim we have a just right to go, we shall trespass in mass, and Sunday will be the opening of our campaign." Not everyone was on board. More conservative Rambling groups in the area wrote editorials denouncing their plan, saying it would hurt the cause for expanded access to the countryside. One editorial argued that trespassing was fine, but it should be done alone, or with just one or two people, quietly, neatly, and successfully. The police were well aware of the plans to trespass at Kinderskout and Benny Rothman's role
乡村美景的权利。无论我们声称我们有正当权利去哪里，我们都将集体私闯，而周日将是我们行动的开幕式。”并不是所有人都赞同。当地更保守的漫步组织写了社论，谴责他们的计划，称这会损害争取扩大乡村通行权的事业。一篇社论辩称，私闯是可以的，但应该独自一人，或者只带一两个人，悄悄地、干净利落地、成功地进行。警察对金德斯考特的私闯计划以及本尼·罗斯曼在其中的角色，
in all of it, and on the day of the event they tried to serve him with an injunction to keep him from going. The police knew he was coming and he arrived by bicycle and they all expected him to come by train so they were kind of hanging out at the train station. Rothman makes it to the trespass and finds about 400 other people are there too. Mostly young people below the age of 21, a lot of men, but some women too. They're wearing old army tops and multi-colored sweaters and khaki shorts and worn work boots. This is kind of the standard hiking garb of the day and for whatever reason they carry these enormous rucksacks they're considered like the thing to do at the time.
一清二楚。在活动当天，他们试图向他送达禁令，阻止他前往。警察知道他要来，而他是骑自行车来的，他们都以为他会坐火车来，所以他们基本上都在火车站闲逛。罗斯曼成功参与了私闯，并发现大约有 400 人也在那里。大部分是 21 岁以下的年轻人，男性居多，但也有一些女性。他们穿着旧军装上衣、多色毛衣、卡其短裤和磨损的工作靴。这可以说是当时标准的徒步装束，不管出于什么原因，他们背着巨大的背包，这在当时被认为是一件很酷的事情。
They co-opten wool bear eyes on the heads, so it was a very, very motley crew, I think. This motley crew of hikers gathered with their braze and rucksacks at the base of the mountain. And Benny Rothman gave a speech about taking back the rights they lost in the enclosure acts of the 17 and 1800s. And he emphasized that the trespass on Kinderskout was meant to be peaceful. And with that, the group set off of the 17 and 1800s. Any emphasize that the trespass on Kinderskout was meant to be peaceful.
他们还在头上戴着羊毛贝雷帽，所以我觉得这是一群非常非常杂牌的人。这群形形色色的徒步者带着他们的贝雷帽和巨大的背包聚集在山脚下。本尼·罗斯曼发表了一讲关于夺回他们在 17 和 18 世纪圈地法案中失去的权利的演讲。他强调，对金德斯考特的私闯旨在保持和平。就这样，这群人出发了。任何强调金德斯考特私闯旨在保持和平的人。
And with that, the group set off of the mountain. The other thing they did was sing. They quite often sang when they went out rambling. And they were singing songs like the Internationali and that sort of thing. And that, of course, showed their political leaning as well. Communist. The Ramblers were in a good mood as they had.
就这样，这群人朝着山出发了。他们做的另一件事就是唱歌。他们外出漫步时经常唱歌。他们唱着《国际歌》之类的歌曲。当然，这也展现了他们的政治倾向。共产主义者。漫步者们心情很好，因为他们。
They sang and talked. There were some police behind them keeping an eye on things and huffing to keep up with the pace of the young walkers. At one point, a group of gamekeepers approached them, wagging their sticks in a small scuffle ensued. One gamekeeper kind of rolls over and hurts his ankle. That's the extent of the scuffle. Eventually, the ramblers made their way back to the bottom. The trespass had been a success. They'd openly walked on Kinder Scout
他们一路唱歌聊天。有一些警察跟在他们后面，密切注视着情况，并气喘吁吁地跟上年轻步行者的步伐。有一次，一群猎场看守人向他们走来，挥舞着手中的棍子，随后发生了一场小规模冲突。一个看守人摔倒了，扭伤了脚踝。这就是冲突的全部程度。最终，漫步者们回到了山脚下。私闯取得了成功。他们公开走上了金德斯考特，
and no one had been able to stop them. And it probably all would have ended right there with nothing much gained or lost on either side. if the police hadn't decided to make some arrests Rothman and five other ring leaders. They're arrested at this time. Trust passing wasn't even an arrestable offense So the police came up with another charge incitement to riotous assembly one rambler got off, but the rest were convicted. And they're given prison sentences from two to six months.
没有人能够阻止他们。如果警察没有决定逮捕一些人——罗斯曼和其他五名领头人——这一切可能就会在那里结束，双方都没有什么收获或损失。他们在这个时候被逮捕。私闯甚至都不是一项可逮捕的罪行，所以警察想出了另一项罪名：煽动聚众闹事。一名漫步者被释放了，但其余的人都被定罪了。他们被判处两到六个月不等的监禁。
But when the sentence was handed down by the judge, that actually united the ramblers' cause, and they all thought this was terrible, you know, just for walking on the more as people being sent to prison. Suddenly, there was this huge amount of awareness in the general public about walking rights. This was like a national news item at the time. And people were sympathetic. And it would set in motion changes that would transform how England thinks about private property. It's been described as one of the most successful acts of civil disobedience ever in the history
但当法官宣判时，这反而团结了漫步者的事业，他们都认为这太可怕了，你知道的，仅仅因为在荒野上散步就把人送进监狱。突然之间，广大公众对步行权的意识空前高涨。这就像当时的国家级新闻。人们都很同情他们。这将引发一系列变革，重塑英格兰对私人财产的看法。它被描述为这个国家历史上，
of this country. The whole thing is even memorialized in song. There was a guy on the trespass named Jimmy Miller. He eventually became a pretty well-known folk singer in England and changed his name to And you enroute the song based on the Master's Press called The Manchester Ambla. Do you know the words? You're not going to ask me to sing it, are you? I actually, yeah. I really want you to sing it. I can sing the chorus, but I think you should get a recording, really.
最成功的公民不服从运动之一。整个事件甚至在一首歌中被纪念。私闯人群中有一个叫吉米·米勒 (Jimmy Miller) 的人。他后来成为了英格兰一位相当著名的民谣歌手，并改名为。你一路上根据大师们的行动创作了这首歌，名叫《曼彻斯特漫步者》(The Manchester Ambla)。你知道歌词吗？你不会让我唱吧？我其实，对。我真的很想让你唱。我可以唱副歌，但我觉得你真该弄个录音。
I'm a Rambler, I'm a Rambler from Manchester Way. I get all my pleasure, the heart maul and way. I may be a wage slave on Monday, but I have my freedom on Sunday. The day was just ending and I was descending. It is the anthem for the trespasser in this country and it'll be played at my funeral. After the trespass, the Rambling Groups continued to push for expanded access. There were more trespasses. In 1951, when Britain opened its first national park,
我是一个漫步者，一个来自曼彻斯特路的漫步者。我所有的快乐，都在荒野之路上。我周一可能是个出卖劳力的奴隶，但我周日在追求自由。白昼刚刚结束，我正在下山。这是这个国家私闯者的赞歌，它将在我的葬礼上播放。私闯事件发生后，漫步者组织继续推动扩大通行权。有了更多的私闯。1951 年，当英国开放其第一个国家公园时，
it was in the peak district where the Kindre Scout trespass took place. This was no accident. Years of negotiations between the Ramblers and the landowners and legislators in the area had paved the way. But it wasn't until the year 2000 that the Ramblers got what they'd always wanted. An act of parliament that opened up huge swaths of the country, where people could roam free.
它就位于金德斯考特私闯事件发生的峰区。这不是巧合。漫步者与当地的地主和立法者之间多年的谈判为此铺平了道路。但直到 2000 年，漫步者才得到了他们一直想要的东西。一项议会法案开放了大片土地，人们可以在那里自由漫游。
The countryside and rights of wayact, and that opened up mountains, moors, heaths, downs. Those are just kind of fancy English words for unimproved grassland. And now we do have the right to roam in open country which is what those lads in 1932 were fighting for. The 2000 act opened up about 7% of the land in England and 21% in whales on which you are free to roam, meaning you don't even have to stay on a trail. You can truly just wander around and 7% may not sound like a lot. But between that and other designated trails, where there are more restrictions, you can
《乡村与通行权法案》（The countryside and rights of wayact），该法案开放了山脉、荒原、石楠荒原、丘陵。这些只是英国人对未改良草地的一些花哨称呼。现在我们在开阔的乡村确实拥有了漫游权，这正是 1932 年那些小伙子们为之奋斗的目标。2000 年的法案开放了英格兰大约 7% 的土地和威尔士 21% 的土地，在这些土地上你可以自由漫游，这意味着你甚至不必呆在小径上。你真的可以四处闲逛，7%听起来可能不多。但在那以及其他有限制的指定小径之间，你现在，
now pretty easily walk across England, just like Katie's dad did. A small footnote. The year after my dad rambled across Madonna's property, she actually sued to keep people from wandering around out there. The government ended up allowing her to close off a lot of her estate, but did keep some small amount of it open to ramblers. Madonna wasn't the only person with concerns about ramblers. When the countryside and rights of way act past,
可以非常轻松地穿过英格兰，就像凯蒂的爸爸做的那样。一个小插曲。在我爸爸在麦当娜的房产上漫步的一年后，她实际上起诉阻止人们在那里四处闲逛。政府最终允许她关闭了她的大部分庄园，但确实保留了其中一小部分对漫步者开放。麦当娜并不是唯一对漫步者感到担忧的人。《乡村与通行权法案》通过时，
a lot of landowners feared the worst. You know, everyone was worried about people sniffing glue out on the countryside and people being mowed down by tractors and wildly fornicating. Like, this was all in the newspapers. Like, people were really worried, but none of that stuff turned out to be true. In addition to Britain, a bunch of other European countries also have partial right to Rome systems. Meaning some, but not all private property, is accessible to walkers. But then there are countries where the right is even further expanded.
许多地主担心最坏的情况发生。你知道的，每个人都担心人们在乡间吸胶水，担心人们被拖拉机碾过，还有疯狂的性交。就像，这些都在报纸上登过。就像，人们真的很担心，但事实证明这些都不是真的。除了英国之外，其他一些欧洲国家也拥有部分漫游权系统。这意味着部分而非全部私人财产对步行者开放。但还有一些国家的权利进一步扩大。
Norway, Finland, Sweden has this thing called Alamansrotten, which means every man's right. And this means you can walk over Kauppästjö, this means you can walk over cow pasture. This means you can walk through the woods. This means you can access virtually the whole countryside. In the United States, we have a system of national and state parks, but we don't have any rights to wander through private property. And in some places, you might even get shot for doing it.
挪威、芬兰、瑞典有一种叫做 Alamansrotten 的东西，意思是“每个人的权利”（every man's right）。这意味着你可以在奶牛牧场上行走，这意味着你可以在奶牛牧场上行走。这意味着你可以穿过树林。这意味着你几乎可以进入整个乡村。在美国，我们有国家公园和州立公园系统，但我们没有任何在私人财产中漫游的权利。在某些地方，你甚至可能会因此被枪杀。
The idea of opening up private land to the public seems almost un-American, but this wasn't always the case. Yeah, this is kind of like a forgotten chapter of American history. Americans who were uninslaived, we had the right to roam from the colonial days up until the Civil War. In the early days of this country, it was common practice to hunt and fish on private land if it wasn't enclosed by offense. In fact, the Pennsylvania delegation to the Constitution even tried to get this enshrined
向公众开放私人土地的想法似乎有些不美式，但情况并非一直如此。是的，这有点像是美国历史上被遗忘的一章。未被奴役的美国人，从殖民地时期一直到内战，我们都拥有漫游权。在这个国家的早期，如果在没有用栅栏围起来的私人土地上狩猎和钓鱼是常见的做法。事实上，宪法的宾夕法尼亚代表团甚至试图将这一点写入，
in the Bill of Rights. That's how important this was to early Americans. Nearly a century later, in an 1862 essay entitled Walking, Henry David Thoreau wrote that he feared that one day, quote, walking over the surface of God's earth, shall be construed to mean trespassing on some gentleman's grounds. This day may have come even sooner than Thoreau feared. Kenogunas says our concept of private property began to change just a few years later after the Civil War, partly because of the end of slavery.
权利法案中。这对早期美国人来说是多么重要。近一个世纪后，亨利·戴维·梭罗 (Henry David Thoreau) 在 1862 年发表的一篇名为《散步》(Walking) 的文章中写道，他担心有一天，“在上帝大地的表面上行走，将被解释为侵入某位绅士的领地。”这一天可能比梭罗担心的还要早到来。肯·伊尔古纳斯说，我们的私有财产概念在内战后仅仅几年就开始改变，部分原因是奴隶制的结束。
One perfect example of this is in 1865, it's the Louisiana legislature, and after the war they passed this resolution, they acknowledged the end of the war and they also do something else. They criminalize trespassing. Now why would they do that right after the Civil War? I think I know why. They did that because now you had a whole bunch of free and independent black people. There were other reasons as well. As Native Americans were forced onto reservations, land grants to the railroads and the Homestead act of 1862 turned great swaths of public land to private ownership
一个完美的例子是 1865 年的路易斯安那州立法机关，战后他们通过了一项决议，他们承认战争结束，同时也做了另一件事。他们将私闯定为刑事犯罪。现在，为什么要在内战结束后马上这样做呢？我想我知道为什么。他们这样做是因为现在你有一大群获得自由和独立的黑人。还有其他原因。随着美洲原住民被迫进入保留地，对铁路的土地赠予以及 1862 年的《宅地法》(Homestead act) 将大片公共土地转为私人所有，
and then came barbed wire. Fences became a lot cheaper, so you could put fences up for livestock, so suddenly a whole bunch more of the country is enclosed. You have a diversified economy, so people are no longer relying on the land for hunting and fishing and gathering as much as they used to. So when people start chipping away at access rights, you don't have an impassioned group of proponents fighting to
然后是带刺铁丝网的出现。栅栏变得便宜得多，所以你可以为牲畜竖起栅栏，突然之间，这个国家的更多地方被围了起来。你拥有了多元化的经济，所以人们不再像以前那样严重依赖土地进行狩猎、捕鱼和采集。因此，当人们开始侵蚀通行权时，你不会有一群充满激情的支持者在为，
maintain their access rights. But Kennell Gunes thinks we should be fighting for recreational access in this country, where a lot of our public land is concentrated in places that are hard for most people to get to. For instance, Alaska has 329 million acres of our public land. That's 41% of all public land. You look at the five states with the highest percentages of public land. That's Alaska, Nevada, Utah, Idaho, Wyoming. All this land is in states where there aren't that many people. Ilgunas believes a right to roam system could help connect all these disparate pieces of public land and give us a sense of ownership.
维护他们的通行权而战。但肯·伊尔古纳斯认为，我们应该为这个国家的休闲通行权而战，因为我们的大部分公共土地都集中在绝大多数人很难到达的地方。例如，阿拉斯加拥有我们 3.29 亿英亩的公共土地。这占所有公共土地的 41%。看看公共土地比例最高的那五个州。那是阿拉斯加、内华达、犹他、爱达荷、怀俄明。所有这些土地都在人口不多的州。伊尔古纳斯相信，漫游权系统可以帮助将所有这些分散的公共土地连接起来，并赋予我们一种主人翁感。
I think if we bring in a system like the right to roam, you know, we're still going to look at the land as if it's someone's. and give us a sense of ownership. I think if we bring in a system like the right to roam, you know, we're still going to look at the land as if it's someone's. But I think we'll also begin to look at it as if it's sort of hours. And for what it's worth, my dad agrees. He says there's something really special about being able to walk wherever you want. I thought the whole concept of being able to walk wherever you want. I thought the whole concept of being able to walk respectfully across private land was extraordinary. And it was something that just doesn't exist here.
我认为，如果我们引入像漫游权这样的系统，你知道，我们仍然会把这片土地看作是某人的。并赋予我们一种主人翁感。我认为，如果我们引入像漫游权这样的系统，你知道，我们仍然会把这片土地看作是某人的。但我认为我们也会开始把它看作是某种属于我们的东西。无论如何，我爸爸表示赞同。他说，能够随心所欲地去任何地方散步，有一种非常特别的感觉。我认为能够在私人土地上恭敬地行走，整个概念是非凡的。这是这里根本不存在的东西。
We have a lot of public land where you can walk in the US, but this seemed very different. There were so many routes and trails to choose from. It felt like the whole country was open to you. These days, if you ramble across the open grasslands of England or Wales, you'll see the remnants of enclosure, the stone walls and fences. And you'll also see the things meant to help you get past these barriers, the styles which are step letters to help you get over fences, the so-called kissing gates, which are these shaped openings that people can walk through, but livestock cannot,
我们在美国有很多可以散步的公共土地，但这看起来非常不同。有那么多路线和小径可供选择。感觉整个国家都向你敞开。如今，如果你在英格兰或威尔士开阔的草地上漫步，你会看到圈地运动的遗迹——石墙和栅栏。你还会看到旨在帮助你越过这些障碍的东西：绊马石（styles），也就是帮助你翻越栅栏的阶梯梯；所谓的“亲吻门”（kissing gates），这些是形状独特的开口，人们可以穿过，但牲畜不能，
because the fences aren't there to stop you anymore. You just hop over and continue on your way. you just hop over and continue on your way. Kady talks about where she's roaming to after seven years of being with NaNiPi after this. So I'm back with Kady Minkle and one of the things that is really like significant about you, in addition to you being just a person that I adore, is that when I hired you, it was the first moment that the show became like a real show. Like I was really nervous because there was a grown woman, like a professional adult who was leaving a job somewhere to come across the country to work on this show,
因为栅栏已经不再是为了阻止你。你只需跳过去继续赶路。你只需跳过去继续赶路。接下来，凯蒂将谈谈她在 Nanaipi 待了七年之后将去哪里漫游。所以我又和凯蒂·明格在一起了，关于你真正意义上的重大事情之一，除了你是我非常崇拜的人之外，就是当我雇佣你的时候，这是这个节目成为一个真正的节目的那一刻。就像我真的很紧张，因为有一个成年女性，一个专业的成年人，要离开某个地方的工作，跨越大国来这个节目工作，
which there to for had been basically kind of a glorified project. Right. Like, and so do you remember what you were thinking as you were traveling out to come, and then it was just like me and Sam, and Avery was the intern at the time, and what you were thinking?
这个节目以前基本上只算是一个被美化的项目。对。就像，那你还记得你当时旅行过来时的想法吗？当时只有我和萨姆，艾弗里（Avery）当时是实习生，你在想什么？
Oh man, I mean, I was so excited because I think I already knew that the show would become something even bigger than what it was at the time. Although I don't think I could have quite imagined what it's grown into. I remember my dad being kind of like, what is this little podcast? Like what? Like is this actually a good career choice for you? But you know, but it was so exciting.
天哪，我的意思是，我太兴奋了，因为我想我当时已经知道这个节目会变得比当时更大。尽管我当时可能无法想象它后来成长为什么样子。我记得我爸爸有点像，这个小播客是什么？就像什么？这真的是你职业生涯的好选择吗？但是你知道，但这太令人兴奋了。
And I know it's nervous because I didn't necessarily feel like I had to produce stories in the way that I would need to for the show. Like, and I just didn't totally know if I could do it. I had done a handful of my own stories for sure, and then up, but most of what I'd done was produce resound, which you know, because you also produced resound, but was kind of curating other people's documentaries and designing these sound collages that like went in between each piece. And so it wasn't a ton of like making my own work. And so
而且我知道我很紧张，因为我不一定觉得我需要以节目需要的方式来制作故事。就像，我只是完全不知道我是否能做到。我当然自己做过一些故事，还有 up，但我做的大多数事情都是制作 resound，你知道的，因为你也制作过 resound，但它有点像策划其他人的纪录片，并设计穿插在每个片段之间的声音拼贴。所以这并不是制作我自己的作品。所以，
that was going to be new. And like I thought I could do it, but I wasn't positive. So yeah, I was nervous and excited for sure. So the big news for you is you are leaving the show after seven years, but what acts as a solve to my heart is where you're going, because it's really well suited to all the skills you develop doing according to needs. So where are you going to go work? Yeah, so I'm going to work with serial productions, which is the company that makes serial, along with other podcasts in more recent years. They did Estown. Most recently, they did the
这将是全新的。虽然我认为我能做到，但我并不百分之百确定。所以，是的，我当时又紧张又兴奋。对你来说最大的新闻是你将在七年后离开这个节目，但稍微抚慰我心的是你要去的地方，因为它非常适合你在《根据需要》(according to needs) 制作过程中培养的所有技能。所以你要去哪里工作？是的，我要去 serial productions 工作，这是制作 serial 的公司，近年来还制作了其他播客。他们制作了 S-Town。最近，他们制作了，
Improvement Association. Nice white parents is a serial production. They were recently acquired by The New York Times, but the show remains very close with this American life and shares staff back and forth. But yeah, I'm so excited and nervous. In a lot of the same ways I was nervous to come work for you. It's just like, so it's a new thing and I hope I can do it and I think I can but yeah, but yeah, I know you can and it just seems like a really good fit for what you're interested in right now Yeah, and and all the things that you get to do and I'm so excited for you. It feels so right Thanks, Roman like I don't even know like if this means you're gonna do cereal like original season four or five or or if you're gonna do something brand new and I don't even know if you know. I don't know if you can tell me who the killer is before it starts because I could do really well in a betting pool if that happened or what I just don't know. But I think it's pretty exciting.
《改善协会》(Improvement Association)。《好白人父母》(Nice White Parents) 是一个 serial 制作。他们最近被《纽约时报》收购了，但这个节目与《This American Life》保持着密切的联系，并且人员互通。但是，是的，我既兴奋又紧张。在很多方面，就像我当初为你工作时一样紧张。这就像，这是一个新事物，我希望我能做到，我想我可以，但是，是的，但是，是的，我知道你可以，而且这似乎非常符合你目前感兴趣的方向。是的，还有你所能做的一切，我为你感到高兴。感觉太对了。谢谢你，罗曼，我都不知道这是否意味着你要制作 cereal 的原创第四季或第五季，或者你要做全新的东西，我甚至不知道你是否知道。如果在开始之前你能告诉我谁是凶手，我在赌局里就能赢得很漂亮，或者别的什么，我只是不知道。但我认为这挺令人兴奋的。
Yeah, I don't really know what I'm going to be working on. I think they have a few kind of leads on stories that need someone to go out and see if there's really anything there. So, it's just like do some initial reporting on, like spend a couple of months just like chasing leads. So I get the feeling it'll be something like that, but I have actually no idea what they have got. And I think they try to keep that stuff pretty secret. But yeah, I'm so excited.
是的，我真的不知道我要做什么。我想他们对一些故事有一些线索，需要有人出去看看那里是否真的有什么东西。所以，这就像做一些初步的报道，花几个月的时间追查线索。所以我感觉会是类似的事情，但我其实不知道他们有什么。而且我想他们会把那些事情保密得很好。但是，是的，我太兴奋了。
And Julie Snyder, who, gosh, what is her actual title over there? President? She runs the show. She runs the show, yeah. And she was a long time editor at The American Life. But she was such a great cheerleader of according to me. I called her at the very beginning of the project and asked if I could ask some questions about,
还有朱莉·斯奈德 (Julie Snyder)，天哪，她在那里真正的头衔是什么？总裁？她运营这个节目。她运营这个节目，是的。她曾是《This American Life》的资深编辑。她是《根据需要》的超级大啦啦队队长。在这个项目刚开始时，我给她打电话，问我是否可以问一些问题，
basically about how they made serial season three because I always felt like season three, which is the one about the criminal justice system in Cleveland and the sort of municipal court system there and all these like criminal cases that were going through that system. I always felt like maybe that was the closest kind of model that I could imagine for according to me, just that it would be a story about a system and about like a very large thing
基本上是关于他们是如何制作 serial 第三季的，因为我一直觉得第三季——就是关于克利夫兰刑事司法系统和那里的市政法院系统以及通过该系统的所有这些刑事案件的那一季——我一直觉得这可能是我能为《根据需要》想象的最接近的模型，它只关于一个系统和一个非常宏大的事情的故事，
that probably didn't have like a single narrative over all the episodes, it was probably going to be several stories that helped you understand this big landscape. And so, yeah, Julie was just so generous, letting me ask questions about how they made that, and then occasionally, throughout the process, we would check in. And so I'm so excited to work with her. She seems like a great, great boss. Not as good as you, I'm sure. I know, I know, of course. It goes to the same. But yeah, I mean, I don't know. I don't know what else to say. I'm just like excited and so kind of humbled by it. Yeah.
可能在所有剧集里没有单一的叙事，它可能由几个故事组成，帮助你理解这个宏大的全景。所以，是的，朱莉非常慷慨，让我问一些关于他们是如何制作那个节目以及在整个过程中我们偶尔会进行交流的问题。所以我非常高兴能和她一起工作。她看起来是个非常非常棒的老板。当然不如你，我确信。我知道，我知道，当然。这不言而喻。但是，是的，我的意思是，我不知道。我不知道该说什么。我只是感到兴奋，并为此感到受宠若惊。是的。
Well, I think it's great. And once you get a taste for doing that long form thing for a couple of years, like I don't think you really could go back to doing like a bunch of pieces for us. Like one of the things that happened during the period of time where you're with a coordinator in need working on it. You know, he's spent two years
嗯，我觉得这很棒。一旦你体验了几年做那种长篇大作的感觉，我就觉得你真的回不到为我们做一堆短片的状态了。就像在你和《根据需要》合作期间发生的事情之一。你知道，他花了两年时间，
just going out talking to people, building relationships, doing that sort of stuff that reporters do. And we definitely would strive to accommodate like doing that again and doing that with more like spin-offs of nine IPI. But there's just something about going to the team that is just so excellent at that in particular,
到处跑，跟人聊天，建立关系，做记者们做的那种事。我们绝对会努力适应再次这样做，并利用 9PI 的更多衍生产品来做到这一点。但有些事情，就是去找那个在这方面特别优秀的团队，
like really hones in on that. And learning from them, which I just think it's so exciting. So I am unbelievably pleased for you and I can't wait to hear what you make. As soon as I am to see you go and not see you on the meetings and you can still show up in the meetings and be on the slack if you want to. I'm really going to miss our slack. I feel like especially in the last year when we haven't gotten to see each other, the Slack is just like, yeah. I think Avery used to say that it was her favorite social media and it's like, I basically
真正专注于此。向他们学习，这让我觉得太棒了。所以我为你感到无比高兴，我迫不及待地想听到你的作品。虽然看到你离开，以后在会议上看不到你，我也很难过——如果你愿意，你仍然可以出现在会议上并在 Slack 上露面。我真的会怀念我们的 Slack。我觉得尤其是过去一年我们没能见面的时候，Slack 就像是，是的。我想艾弗里过去常说这是她最喜欢的社交媒体，就像，我基本上，
feel that way too. Totally. But head and shoulders, my favorite social media, honestly. So before you head off to cereal and do your long form investigative piece, is there anything that you want to talk about in terms of your time here or talk to the audience about or anything that you want to reflect on? I think it's hard to imagine any other show where
也有这种感觉。完全。不过说实话，毫无疑问，这是我最喜欢的社交媒体。所以在你前往 serial 并开始你的长篇调查报道之前，关于你在这里的时光，你有什么想聊的，或者想对听众说的话，或者有什么想反思的吗？我想很难想象还有哪个节目，
the audience felt like such a community that was sort of in on it with us. Like our audience has been just such a nice group to make work for. You know, and a group of people that like gets in touch to tell us what a good job we're doing or how much they like to something. I just, I don't know if another, well, I guess I haven't worked on many other shows, but like, it feels kind of unique to us. I think it's a, I've worked on other shows and I think there's something special about it. I think there's something like, there's a way in which they take in and interpret the stories that we tell and bring it into their lives in a way that I've never experienced on
听众会感觉像是一个与我们同甘共苦的社区。就像我们的听众一直是一群非常棒的人，为他们工作很开心。你知道，他们会主动联系我们，告诉我们我们做得有多好，或者他们有多喜欢某个东西。我只是，我不知道另一个——好吧，我想我没在其他很多节目工作过，但——这感觉对我们来说挺独特的。我想这是一个，我在其他节目工作过，我觉得它有些特别之处。我觉得有一种方式，他们吸收和诠释我们讲述的故事，并将其带入他们的生活，这是我在其他节目中从未体验过的。
another show. Yeah, but that's felt so nice. And the show for me has just been such a great place to get to kind of find my own voice and play and try new things. And I feel like we've done such a great range, and I've gotten to do a great range of like these kind of smaller, joyful stories, sort of like the right to Rome and then these like bigger sprawling like epics. Like the couple episodes I did on the Belmer Mirror, the housing development in Amsterdam and then obviously like according to need, but it's been such a great place to figure out who I am as a producer and I think that's always changing or I think it should always be changing.
另一个节目。是的，但这感觉太好了。这个节目对我来说是一个非常棒的地方，让我能够找到自己的声音，去玩耍，尝试新事物。我觉得我们做出了非常棒的跨度，我得以尝试各种各样的、更小巧、更快乐的故事，比如《漫游权》，然后是这些更大、更广阔的史诗。比如我在贝尔米尔 (Belmer Mirror)——阿姆斯特丹的住宅开发项目——上做的几集，然后显然还有《根据需要》，但这里真的是一个弄清楚我作为一名制片人是谁的绝佳地方，我觉得这总是在改变，或者我觉得它应该一直在改变。
But yeah, I just, I just, like, loved my time here and loved creating work for our audience in particular. Yeah, yeah, it's really, I think it's very special. And I can't imagine the show without you in a lot of ways. I mean, you just gave so much heart to what we did and so much rigor to what we did. And even though, like, I think you're innate interest and architecture was pretty low. But you'd always bring characters and bring story and stakes and stuff. And I think it raised all of our games so much. And then like this development of doing according to need as this really compelling and character driven look at a system,
但是，是的，我只是，我只是，非常热爱在这里的时光，特别是为我们的听众创作作品。是的，是的，真的，我觉得这非常特别。在很多方面，我无法想象没有你的节目。我的意思是，你为我们的工作倾注了太多的心血，为我们的工作付出了如此严谨的态度。尽管，就像，我认为你对建筑的天然兴趣可能相当低。但你总是能带来人物、故事、利害关系和诸如此类的东西。我认为这大大提升了我们所有人的水平。然后就像把《根据需要》发展成一个对系统极具吸引力且以人物为驱动的视角，
it was just like groundbreaking and beautiful. I've always wanted to create a place for you know, people to do their best work and feel comfortable and feel supported and that involves moving on. So I think this is a bittersweet moment, but a really good moment. And so I'm really, really happy for you. And we will figure it out without you, but we definitely will suffer from your absence. So take care. Okay. Bye. 99% Invisible was Produced This Week by Katie Mingle. The Right to Rome episode was originally broadcast in June 2018, mixed by Sheree Fusef, music by our director of Sound, Sean Rihau. The Lany Hall is the executive producer, Kurt Colesette, is the digital director.
这简直是开创性和美丽的。我一直想为人们创造一个地方，你知道的，让他们发挥出最佳水平，感到舒适和支持，而这需要向前看。所以我认为这是一个苦乐参半的时刻，但也是一个非常好的时刻。所以我真的、真的为你感到高兴。没有你，我们也会挺过去的，但你的离开无疑会让我们遭受损失。所以保重。好的。再见。《99% Invisible》本周由凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）制作。“漫游权”这集最初于2018年6月播出，由谢里·富塞夫（Sheree Fusef）混音，音乐由我们的声音总监肖恩·里豪（Sean Rihau）制作。莱尼·霍尔（The Lany Hall）是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔塞特（Kurt Colesette）是数字总监。
The rest of the team includes Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Christopher Rubay, Loshamadon, Sophia Klotzger, and me Roman Mars. We are part of a stature and serious exam podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 9.9 P.I. orc, or on Instagram and Reddit too.
团队的其他成员包括克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、维维安·莱（Vivian Leigh）、克里斯托弗·鲁贝（Christopher Rubay）、洛沙马顿（Loshamadon）、索菲亚·克洛茨格（Sophia Klotzger），以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心以北六个街区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@Roman Mars，或者@9.9 P.I. orc，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到。
You can find other shows I love from Stitcher as well as every past episode of this program, including according to need Katie Mingles, Magnum Opus. If you happen to have skipped it just because you're like, oh, this isn't regular 9-9-PI, you should listen to it because it really is amazing. You can find it at 9-9-PI.org. I'm a rembler, I'm a rembler, when I'm listening to pods still no sting from Stitcher or Sirius? Despite all the odds. Ta-da. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以在Stitcher上找到我喜欢的其他节目，以及本节目的每一期往期节目，包括凯蒂·明格的巅峰之作《按需分配》（According to Need）。如果你恰好因为觉得“哦，这不是常规的9-9-PI”而错过了它，你真该听一听，因为它真的很棒。你可以在 9-9-PI.org 上找到它。我是一个漫步者，我是一个漫步者，当我听播客时，Stitcher或Sirius依然没有怨言？历经种种困难。哒哒。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。